detectives investigating the murder of
the little girl on monday night have
arrested a man in connection with our
inquiries the statement from the police
goes on to say that a 35-year-old man
suspected to have been the target of the
shooting has been detained in hospital
on a prison recall after breaching the
terms of his license he will be recalled
to prison to serve the remainder of his
license he will be further questioned in
connection with the murder and remains
in a stable condition detective chief
inspector mark baker also says that our
inquiries continue into the shocking
murder of olivia and supporting her
family as they try to come to terms with
this tragedy i would like to echo the
words of our chief constable yesterday
and appeal to the community to keep
helping this family in every way
possible we will do all we can to take
care of these involved in gun crime off
the street as this arrest demonstrates
this is not the time for anyone who
knows who was responsible to stay silent
it is a time for us all to make
merseyside a place where the use of guns
on our streets is totally unacceptable
and those who use them held to account
if you saw
heard captured or know anything
you can call us directly
and they do give um some numbers there
so that is uh the latest from
merseyside police detectives
investigating the murder of olivia pratt
koble have arrested a man in connection
with their inquiries